I'm told that I was your first paid
acting gig that it involved me in some
way yes but the producer didn't explain
exactly what was going on like I don't
remember this I played a page that was
giving a tour of your old set in New
York NBC yeah on 30 rock I want 30 rock
yeah or a page yeah okay but I was a
page in real life too
okay so I actually wore my real page
uniform on 30 rock as a page well that's
cool yep
so cool so why did we have a scene
together no but I I'm like leading a
tour and I say to a group of people
welcome to Late Night with Conan O'Brien
and then I that really brings back the
memories yeah and then that was it sad
card actually that's cool yeah so in a
way I was I hate to you know kind of
make a big deal out of it but I launched
your career in show business yes I owe
it all to you yeah and since then I
would say we've you know you've been on
this show a lot we've become pals just
say yes yes say yeah better for me we're
like best chums I know it's crazy it's
mind-blowing
I just feel like we're so close now
mm-hmm
you are devastating by the way that's
amazing how you can just you can say
things that technically if you read the
transcript er like she's saying very
nice things but you've got that tone
it's just I'm really I'm gonna die ten
years early now it's because it's just
some problem with my vocal cords I think
uh-huh sure yeah I can imagine you as
like a teenager just being like great
idea great idea and an adult just
wanting to die you know yeah that was
the story of my life
[Laughter]
you